[Musique]
grâce au parc électronucléaire français
la france est championne du monde en
termes d'émissions de gaz à effet de
serre et que dans le cas de fausses
informations qui sont diffusés notamment
par les réseaux anti nucléaires epr aux
éoliennes
les sondages montrent que beaucoup de
français pensent que les centrales
nucléaires et même des émissions de co2
qui est totalement faux puisque
l'électricité nucléaire en termes de co2
et l'électricité la plus propre et la
france est championne du monde en la
matière et donc moi je me réjouis que
grâce à nos centrales nucléaires la
france peut s'enorgueillir
nonobstant ce que nous dit la jolie v
tacle berg d'être un pays phare dans le
monde en termes de lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique même si le
nucléaire ne produisait pas du tout de
co2 on ne pourrait pas résoudre la
problématique du réchauffement
climatique en construisant des centrales
nucléaires on se rend bien compte le
nombre d'années qui sont nécessaires
pour construire les centrales nucléaires
le père de flamanville en est un bon
exemple
alors que le réchauffement climatique
fait un une une question imminente
donc ce n'est pas par le nucléaire qu'on
va résoudre le problème du réchauffement
climatique
c'est une fausse bonne solution et c'est
une solution qui consiste à impacter les
générations futures
avec bien d'autres problèmes encore à
savoir notamment la gestion des déchets
[Musique]
l'allemagne vous voyez vous a fait la
politique de l'arrêt du nucléaire et du
développement des énergies renouvelables
et notamment de son parc éolien qui se
présente à peu près 30% de son
électricité et l'allemagne et mais dix
fois plus de gaz à effet de serre que la
france dix fois plus c'est un défi et un
des exemples les plus les plus mauvais
qui soit en termes d'émissions de gaz
etc et même en guerre elle pourrait on
connaît que si nous sommes vertueux en
terme d'émissions de gaz à effet de
serre ces casses à notre parc
électronucléaire l'une éoliennes
fonctionnent 20 % globalement de son
temps moyen maximal de production et
c'est pour ça qu'on est obligé
d'utiliser du charbo en compensation de
l'intermittence des organes et c'est
pour ça que l'allemagne est le champion
du monde d'émissions de gaz à effet de
serre il n'y a pas plu non vertueux que
les énergies renouvelables ne sont pas
des outils de la transition écologique
mais ce qu'ils sont des outils de la
trahison écologie l'allemagne est en
train de sortir non seulement du
nucléaire mais également du charbon et
si vous regardez les courbes le fait aux
deux réduit beaucoup plus vite en
allemagne qu'en france il est encore au
dessus de ce qu'il est en france c'est
vrai je vous la corde mais réduit
beaucoup plus vite
il faut être honnête monsieur moi je
vais bien tout entendre à condition
qu'on soit honnête dans ses
démonstrations si vous regardez au
niveau mondial le nombre de centrales
nucléaires en construction est bien
inférieur au nombre de centrales qu'on
est amené à arrêter et qu'on va devoir
déconstruire et d'ailleurs ça va nous
coûter les yeux de la tête de
déconstruire toutes ses centrales
nucléaires vous le savez fort bien mais
il faut bien le faire
quelle que soit leur durée de vie un
jour ou l'autre il faudra les
déconstruire
donc nous sommes nous sommes dans nous
sommes dans une fuite en avant en france
avec nucléaire regardons les choses en
face moi je n'ai pas envie que mon pays
la france
on se retrouve dans le wagon de queue
des énergies renouvelables au niveau
européen
de toute façon bien la recherche et
développement que l'on peut consacrer à
cette question avec les économies qu'on
fasse sur les subventions gigantesques
ont fait sur les éoliennes développées
des petites unités comme le fait la
chine les etats unis ou la russie
beaulieu de faire des grosses centrales
nucléaires faire des petites unités avec
des unités flottantes
la russie est en train de le faire
actuellement donc moi je suis très
optimiste surtout il faut qu'on arrête
l'éolien les militants l'éolien nous en
mettent qui valent même pas 100 %
renouvelable alors qu'avec intermittence
c'est pas possible
doc là moi je dis on économise les 200
milliards d'euros qu'on veut nous
imposer et ont fait de la recherche et
développement et vous paierez notre pays
s'en portera mieux et sera un des pays
encore champion de monde en termes
d'émissions de gaz à effet serre j'étais
ravie de vous rencontrer monsieur de
cette édition une fergie pas monsieur de
remplacer le tout nucléaire par du tout
éolien fastre est idiot mais il s'agit
de remplacer le nucléaire par l'ensemble
du panel des énergies renouvelables
selon les régions fait plus d eau lien
fait plus de photovoltaïque fait plus
diderot lien ces puces d'hydraulique
c'est plus de cogénération c'est plus
tout à fait possible en art en alsace on
amène de la géothermique tout tout est
possible mais arrêtons cette religion
française la france est un pays qui a
une religion c'est la religion du
nucléaire et nous nous battons contre
cette religion d'une hauteur parce que
monsieur entre le nucléaire et l'éolien
il reste une place pour l'intelligence